de mener que l'appoint de bonsoir
bonsoir il ya beaucoup de gens qui se
demandent si la chute de l'emploi
puisque le ministre girerd parle
d'interruption si c'est quelque chose de
temporaire comment vous évaluez la chose
en fait c'est temporaire dans la mesure
où on va être capable de réouvrir
l'économie assez rapidement comme prévu
donc en ce moment au québec on ne
fermait plus que 60% d'économie si on se
fie aux données par exemple de google
qui rapporte les géo localisation des
déplacements des gens donc une fois
qu'on se met à rire ouvrir l'économie va
y avoir des rappels au travail on a déjà
observé un bonheur anecdotique beaucoup
de rappel ou de gens qui pensent avoir
happé dans les prochaines semaines par
contre dans certaines industries
on pense le commerce de détail toutes
les industries liées au tourisme
services de prendre beaucoup plus de
temps avant qu'on ait un rappel au
travail et même dans l'institut la
restauration par exemple certaines
provinces qui parle de seulement
admettre 50% de la capacité d'avant donc
il pourrait y avoir un certain nombre
d'emplois seraient perdus de manière
permanente
oui alors les données sur le chômage ne
disent pas tout quand même ce qu'on
appelle le taux d'emploi puis on va le
voir a chuté c'est à dire le nombre
d'emplois par rapport à l'ensemble de la
population
effectivement lorsqu'on regarde le tout
chômeur souvent on va pas prendre en
compte en fait les gens qui ne cherchent
pas un emploi donc un taux chômage à 13
% c'est très élevé mais même le ca ca
sous-estiment un peu l'ampleur du
problème quand on regarde le graphique
du taux d'emploi qui va essayer à 52
pour ça ce qui veut dire seulement un
peu plus d'un canadien sur deux
travaillé le mois dernier on voit bien
fixé qu'on n'avait pas cessé parce
qu'une erreur tellement la ligne b c'est
rapide c'est du jamais vu mais c'est la
réalité est en fait je peux même vous
dire
selon statistique canada il y avait 2
millions personnes additionnelles qui
ont apporté travailler 0 par le
modernisme donc le nom de gens infectés
par le virus par le travail plus élevé
encore que ce qu'on voit et c'est
probablement réfléter dans le 7 millions
de canadiens qui ont appliqué pour la
prestation canadien
d'urgence c'est votre vrai donné ça pour
comprendre l'ampleur
les sept millions deux cent mille
personnes qui ont demandé la prestation
canadienne d'urgence mais en fait oui
c'est celle qui reflète le mieux selon
nous le nom de gens qui ont été affectés
de près ou de loin par le père ni virus
à un point où ils ont besoin d'une
assistance financière
mais c'est effectivement lorsqu'on
creuse dans les données de l'emploi ça
reflète assez bien ce nombre de gens là
matin avec trois millions de gens qui
ont perdu leur emploi
un autre 2 millions qui on cherche pas
puis on parle aussi de gens qui ont
travaillé 0 à redon les chiffres
fonctionnaires 6 me à ce niveau le logo
de nick j'aime regarder moi c'est le
nombre d'heures travaillées
parce que ça ne manque pas on englobe
tout l'impact web et regardons justement
graphique que vous avez préparé pour
nous qui montre clairement en fait le la
carte du canada où on voit le nombre
d'heures travaillées qui a chuté partout
au canada mais surtout au québec
trente six pour ça pourquoi en fait au
québec on est fermée l'économie
relativement plutôt que dans d'autres
provinces et on a fermé plus de secteurs
de l'économie donc par exemple
l'industrie de la construction au québec
on le ferme et assez doux c'est parce
qu'on a fait dans toutes les autres
provinces même on le ferait plus tard
ailleurs où parfois on n'a pas fermé du
tout ça a un impact sur les données de
l'emploi plus au québec ses tics
montréal sont le plus affectés que les
épisodes grande et donc par exemple on
voit pas sur le graphique on me les a
travaillé à montréal ont baissé
d'environ 37% le ski est vraiment grosse
différence par exemple avec winnipeg qui
poussent aux alentours de 20%
non simplement au québec la contraction
économique en raison de l'impact de
l'épidémie est plus importante
qu'ailleurs
est ce que vous diriez que le pire est
déjà passé le pire sur le plan
économique du marché du travail de
l'emploi
probablement on ira instable ça va
dépendre de l'évolution de l'épidémie
mais on air on installe qu'on a
l'impression qu'on parle de réouvrir
l'économie
partout au canada c'est déjà commencé
d'ailleurs la saskatchewan et le
manitoba ont commencé cette semaine un
peu à réouvrir la région et c'est déjà
permis par exemple de faire des petits
rassemblements dans certaines provinces
atlantiques
donc on s'attend à voir quand même une
création substantielles d'emplois au
mois de mai dans la plupart des
provinces pour montréal ça semble tarder
on parle maintenant de lui ouvrir
l'économie plus tard au moins deux nuits
plaisir la fin du mois de mai dont il
pourrait avoir un certain délai entre
québec et les autres provinces au point
de vue de la création d'emplois mais
écoutez c'est plus on peut pomper
seulement permet l'économie une fois
donc les emplois qui ont été perdus
cette fois ci on peut pas vraiment leur
perdent encore ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est seulement qu'on va avoir un retour
au travail
oui mais c'est pas tous les emplois
nécessairement qu'ils vont revenir
effectivement c'est comme on disait au
début beaucoup d'emplois dans les 1 6
qui était déjà fragile avant la
récession dans le styx détail
particulièrement élevé avec aldo
fermetures de succursales ou des modèles
d'affaires qui sont mises au défi par
une nouvelle technologie par les achats
en ligne sur leurs sons vont avoir plus
de difficultés à rouvrir le même et avec
la baisse d'achalandage
il pourrait y avoir des pertes d'emplois
plus permanent dans ces secteurs le
secteur manufacturier secteur de la
construction est plus optimiste par
rapport à ceux où tous les services
professionnels ce qu'on peut trés
continue à travailler à la maison
notamment ne lui avait pas eu beaucoup
de pertes d'emplois un mot en terminant
sur la note de crédit on parlait d
observation de moody's pour le québec
la note de crédit du canada avec un
déficit de 250 300 milliards et elle à
risque selon vous est lié à un risque
dans la mesure où on n'aurait pas une
reprise économique très important l'an
prochain ou même à partir du deuxième
trimestre on ne veut ou moïse a
d'ailleurs réaffirmé dans une mise à
jour économique à la fin du mois de mars
la villa ne décris 10,3 du canada on n'a
pas mis en perspective négative sur la
dette qui une perspective négative qui
voudrait dire qu'on s'enligne vers une
décote bientôt mais en raison du fait
qu'on nous dise comme les autres héros à
crédit en cp une reprise rapide on ne
peut décider de décoter tout de suite on
peut se permettre
déficit très important cette année sur
deux ans on pense que ça aura un impact
sur la note des critiques parfait on
aura on va suivre ça de près les mises à
jour des gouvernements viendront
probablement fin juin dominique lapointe
merci merci beaucoup